we're now hearing from Russian President
Vladimir Putin who is attending via
video link let's listen in distinguished
prime minister
dear colleagues at the outset I would
like to thank
South African France for what they have
done during their presidency during
their chairmanship this year
colleagues before me have already given
positive assessment of the brics
activities
and in general
certainly we share these assessments our
group of five countries has rightly
proved to be a credible entity on the
global Arena
with ever growing influence in global
affairs
the Strategic course of brics is aimed
at the future and it meets the
aspirations of the main part of the
International Community the so-called
Global majority
my principle by acting in concert on the
principles of equality partnership
support and account for each other's
interests we deal with the most pressing
issues of global and Regional agenda
the main important thing is that breaks
stands for multiple world order that is
Equitable and built on international law
and the principles of the United Nations
Charter
including respect for the right of every
people to its own development path yeah
some countries promote the hegemony
exceptionality
and the policy of the ongoing
colonialism and neocolonialism
I would like to know
that the aspiration to preserve the
hegemony in the world
led to a dire crisis in Ukraine
first with the help of Western countries
constitutional coup d'etat was carried
out in this country after that those
people who did not agree with this coup
faced a war a war was Unleashed against
them a war of attrition and it lasted
for eight years Russia decided to
support people that fight for their
culture for their traditions for their
language and their future
our actions in Ukraine are Guided by
only one thing to put an end to the war
that was Unleashed by the West
against people in donbas we thank our
colleagues within breaks
that take an active part
in the attempts to put an end to this
situation and to ensure just settlement
by peaceful means
dear colleagues
the main thing is that we unanimously
stand for the shaping of the multi-polar
world order which is genuinely Equitable
and which is building on international
law
the brics countries are building up
their potential as was said the biggest
countries are home to over 3 billion
persons and their share in global GDP as
per purchasing power parity of the
so-called G7 over the past decades
Rick's investment to global economy have
doubles and the cumulative export
reached 20 percent of the overall
indicator were successfully implementing
the strategy for brics economic
partnership 2025 namely where
strengthening the five lateral
cooperation on such areas as
diversification of Supply chains
dolorization and transfer to local
currencies in our mutual settlements
digital economy support for small and
medium Enterprises just transfer
Technologies and naturally
active part in this processes is placed
by business community
a great deal of effort is invested
within the Briggs Business Council and
the brics women's business Alliance that
the host of our meeting President
indicated the leaders of these
organizations are present at this
meeting an important priority for the
brics interaction is the establishment
of new sustainable safe transport Foods
in my address to the Briggs business
forum I talked about the importance of a
speedy development of transcontinental
routes such as the north south Corridor
that would link Russian Northern sea and
Baltic ports to
C terminals in the gulf and in the
Indian Ocean in the future it should
ensure the annual Transit of up to 30
million tons of cargo
we believe that it is high time to
establish a brics permanent Commission
on transport that would deal not only
with the north-south project
but in a broader terms it will deal with
Logistics and transport corridors
development both inter-regional and
Global ones should the partners agree to
that the Russian side could work on this
idea within its chairmanship in 2024 and
certainly we welcome strengthened
interaction Within brics
in terms of global Innovations we look
forward to a more active cooperation
within the brics Global Research
Advanced infrastructure Network
it could be supported and developed by
the special trust fund for its part
Russia is ready to share its experience
and best practices
including when it comes to digital
transformation and the use of artificial
intelligence we also seek to
actively participate in the
implementation of the achieved
Arrangements on the establishment of the
joint working group on nuclear medicine
we seek to swiftly switch into practice
the work of the brics TV ET Corporation
Alliance
we wholeheartedly support the proposal
of South African colleagues to organize
a separate ministerial on women affairs
their role in political economic and
social life of our states should
definitely be enhanced
dear colleagues
next year
Russia will assume brics championship
our chairmanship
will have the following motto
strengthening multilateralism for just
Global development and security
we plan to have some 200 political
economic and public events that will be
hosted by over a dozen Russian cities at
the same time the Briggs Summit is
scheduled for October 2024 it will take
place in the city of Kazan the specific
dates will be agreed upon with
colleagues by diplomatic channels we'll
also have events in the format that has
proved its relevance I'm talking about
fixed plus and brics Outreach during our
chairmanship we would like to do our
utmost to efficiently facilitate the
implementation of decisions adopted at
this Summit including with regard to the
expansion of bricks
we will coordinate closely with Partners
on foreign policy matters we will
jointly work on key International
platforms primarily within the United
Nations will continue regular meetings
of brics National Security advisors
certainly we will prioritize such
urgent tasks as combating terrorism and
the spread of terrorist ideology
as well as combating money laundering
and return of assets gained by criminal
means by the way we thank partners for
their support within the financial
action task force
we hope that we will keep the such
Spirit of solidarity in the future
will contribute to comprehensive
implementation of the strategy for brics
economic partnership 2025
and the development of new long-term
guidelines for cooperation
this includes in our view increasing the
role of states and international
monetary and financial system the
development of interbank Corporation
expanding the use of local currencies
and deepening interactions between tax
customs and anti-monopoly agencies
naturally Russian poeters includes
bolstered partnership in science and
Innovation Healthcare education the
development of humanitarian ties in
general cultural and civilizational
diversity
is one of the pillars of the new
multiple world order and it means the
establishment of integral free space for
cultural exchange art and creativity as
we see it it's high time for partners
within Briggs as well as the SEO and the
community of independent state
and other countries to have a serious
conversation on the future of culture in
the world on preserving and multiplying
Global cultural heritage by the way such
dialogue could be held within the ninth
International cultural Forum which is
scheduled to take place in the city of
Saint Petersburg from November 16th to
18th and certainly Russia will continue
to contribute to context in sports and
youth exchanges namely in June 2024
who plan to have the brics games we
would be happy to welcome teams from the
brics Nations
uh to the next year's International
competition the games of the future they
will take place in the city of Kazan
this is a mix of
Dynamic Sports and popular video games
and technological devices a good
opportunity for contacts and friendly
talks will be given by the world Youth
Festival that will take place in March
next year in the city of Sochi in
conclusion let me once again highlight
that Russia during its chairmanship will
interact in the most constructive way
with Rick's Partners in order to further
enhance the role and credibility of
bricks without any doubt this
credibility will only grow thank you for
your attention
all right we have been listening there
to Russian President Vladimir Putin who
is addressing the brics summit that is
the summit of Brazil Russia India China
and South Africa the 15th Brook Summit
that's taking place in the South African
city of Johannesburg and President Putin
talking about the world that they were
addressing the most pressing issues of
global and Regional and agendas he also
said that Brook stands for a multi-polar
world that is Equitable built on
international law he said and the
principles of the UN Charter he also
went on to talk about what's led to the
Russian invasion of Ukraine though he
didn't use those words of course